so hello everybody I am sitting here
with dr. Timothy petits a-- dr. petit
sa' is a professor of ethics at Holy
Cross and at Hellenic college he is also
now the interim dean at Hellenic College
which gives a an undergraduate level
degree of uh and all kinds of
undergraduate degrees he's also teaching
at the seminary Holy Cross which is a
seminary for priests but I have him here
today for a few reasons one is that for
months for years I would say since about
2015 people have been telling me you
have to talk to dr. Timothy you have to
talk to them and now recently because
I'm making YouTube videos I've had
people watching my videos saying I can't
read this article by by him I've read
this interview with him you have to talk
to him and we had a brief chance of
meeting at I had an event in the fall
but now I am been I have been into his
book which he just public published
called the ethics of beauty and I'm
finding in it all the stuff that I love
that I'm interested in that you guys who
watch this are interested in he talks
about the about complexity how about
these new science of complexity is
really bringing science and religion
together you know the inevitability of
patterns how beauty is important in our
in the way we perceive reality and how
we engage with it so I'm really excited
to get a chance to talk him about his
book and just about his ideas in general
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
maybe maybe dr. Timothy you can maybe
tell us a little bit about yourself
about your position right now and your
journey and then we can dive into some
of your some of what you wrote in your
book yes thank you very much Jonathan
and I also you know was really looking
forward to meeting you at st. T
consonant heard so much about you and
yeah right right now what I'm and and
your talk was so incredible at st.
econ's that yeah it blew me away it was
it was so fantastic but the the right
now I'm the interim dean at Hellenic
College so it's the undergraduate school
in Brookline Mass and I'm wearing a hat
of WVU because my nephew teen okay
office goes there and because I I'm
nursing a head cold and I have to have
to keep my head warm at all time so
forgive me for appearing so casual but
yeah I'm the interim dean of our
undergraduate school we're trying to
launch a revision of our of our core
curriculum we're in the process of
discussing what that might look like I
hope we can get it done we might not but
we have a number of good majors
undergraduate majors it's an Orthodox
Christian community We certainly have
about 50 slots a year open to
undergraduate students because we don't
want to grow so large that we overwhelm
our sister school our big sister the
Holy Cross Creek Orthodox school of
theology they you know the actual
seminary and it's a faith really a
vibrant campus there's a lot of it's a
very holy place actually and and in a
living sense there's a lot of struggle
there but it's it's a holy place well I
think for people watching these videos
people in their 20s and then also people
who are parents and looking at their
kids we're always looking for
opportunities for people to get a
grounding a good intellectual grounding
in in the Christian tradition in the
Orthodox faith so so I hope that people
will look into Hellenic college I know I
will have turned my kid is just turned
15 yesterday and so we're starting to
think about you know hopefully giving
him some kind of ground to face the
with something a way of thinking and
this is what I discovered in your book
which I love you know I haven't gone
through it's very thick but it reads
really well you know it reads very
easily because it's a series of
interviews that we're done with road to
emmaus journal if you you don't know
about this journal it is great as well
it is run by mother nicht area and
here's one of the ones that dr. Timothy
did did there are interviews in there
with andrew gould with father sue them
on justin jana all people that I love
and I think are really in the right
position in terms of reawakening sense
of beauty and a sense of pattern in the
world and so it's done as a series of
interviews and it's very easy to read
and very common sense but it also dives
into some very powerful ideas you know
from the idea of architecture how
architecture is so important I was in
Boston just a month ago at a talk and
you know I I brought up that exact point
that architecture is really the most
important art because it is it is
disappears in a way because you're
living within it it's the space within
within which you live and so urban
planning and architecture is is becomes
the frame of your actual lived existence
so maybe we can start there because you
you you use Christopher Alexander and
Jane Jacobs as some of the basis of the
things you're talking about so maybe you
can explore a little bit with us the
idea of the city as liturgy or the
liturgical aspect of reality and how how
we engage with it um yeah I I do want to
give a shout out to you I just talked to
mother nicht Aria this morning and she
said to say hello and how much she
thinks about you and prays for you all
the time she and I are both spiritual
children of Father Artemia vladimirov
in Moscow so so that's a big connection
mother Nick Terry and I have that's kept
us close she used to be a student here
and when she was she would chase me
around with a tape recorder everything I
said and that's what got into the idea
that I would just write the book as if
it were a series of interviews with her
but we spent so many years editing and
you know she influenced you know the
questions added new questions
and influence all the answers that part
author oh yes she is she is really a
huge influence and and and I think a
basic premise of the book is that you
know within these ancient liturgical
systems that you know a lot of a lot of
Secrets are kind of carried waiting to
be unpacked you know by later
generations and and one of the first one
of the ways that I actually started to
write this book is a student asked me
about a passage in Lars tunberg which
said that from the 4th century east and
west west started to drift apart on the
question of whether the sensual sins are
were the place to begin the spiritual
struggle or the intellectual sins and I
had no idea what that meant that
question and why it was that the East
chose the sensual it seemed so or why
st. Maximus did so I guess before I get
to the Jane Jacobs thing just it's
really my I guess my my operating idea
has been to just treat the church and
and really and other you know
repositories of ancient wisdom as if you
know they're smarter than they look
there's their stuff hidden in there that
it takes a lifetime to to sort of before
you know it takes a lifetime of getting
ready before you can know what they're
saying to you no I agree but I think
there's also one of the problems well
it's a problem and an opportunity is
that there are some things that were
just lived let's say in the ancient
times and were were taken for granted
and so we're not explored intellectually
they were just the water that you swam
in and so now with the Enlightenment and
with this kind of alienated mode of
being that we've had in a one way on one
hand we were alienated but it's actually
an opportunity to now look back into
those systems and see them with a with a
let's say a distance which can help us
understand them in a different way yeah
and and I think you know people really
underestimate the importance of you know
you mentioned Jane Jacobs I think a
second ago and City Planning and
her book the death and life of great
American cities I mean people like that
book you know to get to this issue of
cities for what it says about you know
what it says about urban planning sure
but in the final chapter of the book she
says hey there's this new kind of
science it's called you know the science
of organized complexity and so in 1961
she became the first person to read
reinvent a whole social science you know
urban planning through the lens of this
new science I mean it was she was so far
ahead of her time and and so that was
another major influence in my
intellectual life and I eventually you
know met Jane Jacobs the last five years
of her life we were close and certainly
went to her home many times and you know
I write about that in the book and she
had a huge impact on me and and she
thought I was pretty keen to you know so
I I say that because it's it's important
if you're right if you have someone of
that stature who signs off on something
well that really that really matters mmm
you know that's the ultimate kind of
recommendation so did you feel like for
example someone like her do you feel
like she was able to perceive the
analogies between City Planning and
let's say the religious rituals or the
the sacramental life that that the
Orthodox engage in so in late 1999 I
wrote her for the first time you know I
just you can write any author you want
just send the letter to their publisher
and the author will get it if anyone
wants to and that's when I laid out that
I felt I had discovered that in her in
that book the death and life that cities
were really vast liturgies and that
there were all kinds of very practical
components of city order as she as she
discovered it which looked just like
liturgies you know being the work of the
people cycling through death and life
these patterns of death and rebirth the
love the Wonder the the emergent
character the openness to the the
radical openness to the unknown
crucial for her in cities you know she
thought a city that stopped innovating
wouldn't really be a city anymore it
would just be an overgrown decaying
settlement so when I wrote her that she
said I mean in her first letter back she
said this is the best you know you're
the best interpreter of my work that I'm
aware of and you're showing me what my
own work means hmm and and then she did
something else which was you know so so
interesting and that's why I put it in
this book she said you've I was startled
she said that you've graphs grasps
something that I was groping for in my
forthcoming book the nature of economy
and or the nature of economies I always
forget which it is and I didn't know
what she was talking about it took it
took some time you know but she noticed
first that if cities were liturgies then
we then by extension all self-organized
emergent systems look kind of liturgical
yeah and you basically have a ready-made
reconciliation of science with religion
and it's a it's a gentle reconciliation
and it's it's sturdy yeah this is
something that I've been really pushing
at least for the past four years is to
try to help people understand like the
inevitability of hierarchy and complex
systems and the inevitability of when I
say higher carrying the full hierarchy
and also the engagement with the margin
and the unknown and and let's say the
potentiality on the edge of that
hierarchy and how everything is made
that way there is no there is no
exception to it and and that it helps us
understand let's say neoplatonism in
assert in in a more modern way but then
if you now bring the signs of
consciousness into the realm of also
this complexity fear and you see how
they interrelate with each other how the
inevitability of of the conscious agent
as the let's say the the frame of
multiplicity and unity how you know we
bring things together in love through
our conscious being then all of a sudden
you can see how the Christian answer to
neoplatonism is also there which
the bringing into the incarnational
practice wait it's not just these forms
in almost in an abstract way that kind
of settle into the world but rather the
agent the the incarnate agent is that
let's say the the fulcrum out of which
this is happening and so to me it just
seems like like you said right now is a
critical moment for Christians to to be
able to expound this for people to
understand that this is what we've been
talking about all along one of my
students
her name is Georgia Williams she she
wrote a beautiful paper and arguing that
the that what we call fractal you know
the fractal geometry of nature really
are the hierarchies and once you
understand that the hierarchies are
really fractals then you realize well
well well Marxism collapses because you
know Marxism is the idea that you know
you you could dispense with hierarchy in
favor of a pure democracy you know with
a small D this pure equality of same of
sameness and organic order is fractal
therefore it's in other words it's
hierarchical and so you kind of have to
junk that vision now of course in
patinas and as well as indiana seus what
because it is these are divine systems
it really is the way besides besides
relating to God through the hierarchies
up and down we also all relate directly
hang on and and so we have both
democracy and monarchy in the church but
the idea that you're gonna have just one
of those of course it's death beautiful
images I've seen in your book I was I
was trying to get to as much as I could
you know before our interview but one of
the most beautiful images that you had
in there was this idea it an
interpretation of st. Maximus and this
is something that just comes right into
my thinking as well which is that the
when we talk about the Logie it's not as
if these logi exists as things are you
know a it's more the notion that the
Logie the the Logie are christ
manifesting himself too in a particular
thing so it's like in my particular
reality my own little hierarchical
hierarchical being
it's my vision of Christ which is my
Logie it's the way in which I can
interrelate with Christ and so it's the
same with things as well all things are
a reflection of God are a reflection of
an incarnational principle within their
specific sphere and so it and so it
actually because a lot of people
struggle with the idea of these Logie is
existing independently and it's like
it's not that they exist independently
they exist as a communion of
multiplicity which is constantly
breathing in and breathing out you could
say coming into the life of Christ and
the real reality is the divine logos
there is no other reality besides that
one we just are able to participate in
it you know at at the level in which we
can which is what same excellence is
always saying and father Maximus
Constance who is the Dean of Holy Cross
while I'm the Dean of Hellenic he he
says I think he stresses the idea that
creative things are like mirrors you
know which which which which their
appearance is really their participation
their reflection of the logos according
to their individual you know lobe us
with a small L but the thing that really
helped me there was actually Wendell
Barry in and I think it's hard to think
of you know he's this Western Kentucky
farmer and the greatest spokesman for
American agrarianism and it was funny I
was at Jane Jacobs house one time and we
were talking about him and she didn't
quite get the agrarian the agrarian
thing but he really helped me with the
lowboy because he's always talking about
the ways of the lost ways of farming the
lost ways of animal husbandry the lost
ways of community and I began to see
that the logo were more like the ways
you know it's about and owing and then
on the other side it's it's the way in
which Christ as I say in the book kneels
down to wash the feet of every aspect of
creation in a way that it can accept it
can understand and can live to and it's
a perfect example because we always need
to remember that baptism is identity
forming that's what baptism is you wash
what's not part of the thing
which is not you know you wash off the
externals and then you name the thing
you know the person comes out of the
water you name them it's like it's it
really is and I an identity forming
thing and so the image of Christ washing
the feet of creation I just thought was
it's a beautiful image of how of how on
the one hand there is this power and
authority of naming but at the same time
there's this love and care which is to
grooming almost like that to make sure
that the thing has a form of
completeness so it's a beautiful image
really powerful the it is it's great and
and you know we have I mean a couple
traditions I've noticed is I mean just
in a living way as people do often take
on some quality of the saint whose name
they get at baptism
I mean it's so so obviously with time
that like of course and and then the
another tradition at least we have in in
the Greek Orthodox world and I don't
know if maybe it's just universal is
that you know when the your godparents
put the oil on you that they also give
you one of their particular charisms
that you you become literally their
child you you will have some you will
resemble them in some way like we do
much more so our own parents and I've
seen that a lot too so no I think that
that seems like it's something that
would be inevitable
you know I mean it's hard for it's it's
so funny because it those types of
things when you say them that it's very
difficult for materialists to understand
how how how real and how inevitable
these types of relationships are in
terms of in terms of identity it's it's
as soon as you understand the
inevitability of identity and how
identities happen and how these
multiplicities kind of this potentiality
comes into one and how we participate in
that for others and how we all we all
coexist you could say all the sudden it
everything kind of makes sense one of
the images that you talk about which
really hit me is when you talk about
post enlightenment thinking and you know
I tend to be very anti enlightenment in
my sometimes in my discourse just
because we've had to we grew up with the
we grew up with the with the arrogance
of the Enlightenment so we we want to
you know we just want it hit back but I
feel like the way that
you talk about it as a reconciliation I
think is is far more fruitful yeah you
know how in a way the Enlightenment
created the idea that the human person
is outside of nature and is looking at
things as this weird kind of dis
incarnated light and you still hear that
today you hear people say things like oh
it's just a social convention it's just
a social construct and like okay so
where are you standing for it to just be
a social construct are you somehow above
all of the natural world to see that
these social contracts don't exist in
reality but as soon as you go back into
the natural world actually and it's an
interesting move as soon as you kind of
even take consciousness and put it back
into the natural world all of a sudden
all of a sudden these things start to
flip around and the notion of identity
forming and the idea of communion all of
these elements start to make sense once
again it is it's it's a great moment
we're living in and I think the book was
I wrote the book without an outline
without a plan I just you know it just
unfolded a lot of things I discovered
while writing especially in Chapter four
about so what is the core of the
spiritual path in terms of three
concentric phases of healthy shame and I
think at the by the end of the book
because you know it just reached its
logical conclusion and talking about
Jane Jacobs and the science of organic
complexity because I realized that that
is the beauty first approach to science
and and what Jane Jacobs did in 1961
there now that really should be that
book should guide the university
curricula I mean it that is the book for
me um she said there's these three kinds
of science and they each are good at
something so she she she actually
rescues and saves the Enlightenment
because she shows that it surpassed
itself in the discovery of organic
complexity and you know that's redeeming
and we do need reductive approaches you
know in certain cases we're making
machinery and this and that so all of a
sudden you realize what we need all
three kinds of science but there
always has to be that priority for the
beauty first way or or as I you know we
ought we are so addicted as a culture to
large large quantity information and
high potency information and we have to
train that out of ourselves because it's
such a heady drug and and learn to
appreciate high quality information and
that's what you get through complexity
and through the beauty first way so so
even though all three kinds of science
matter the beauty first way it really
has to govern your heart and in a way
it's what's interesting as well about
this approach is that it it not only is
it a way to kind of solve the
Enlightenment problem or rather
re-appropriate the Enlightenment it also
is a way to deal with the postmodern
problem as well you know because it to
to to talk about these patterns and to
talk about our our us being emerged
immersed in this pattern being part of
the fractal so we're not outside looking
at the fractal we are right so within
the fractal and we are one of its one of
its instantiations you could say and an
important one because we're the one who
can who can then see the other
instantiations of that pattern that this
is also a case and answered to the kind
of postmodern deconstructionist which
still also has almost the viewer as this
weird external thing which is keeps
criticizing things for being constructed
and tries to to point to the logo
centrism of of things and you know in a
way we're saying not in the same way
that i was saying but we're saying yeah
logo centrism is just inevitable you
just can't have reality without some
kind of without without this communion
and essence which appears as but but
it's a bottom-up and top-down approach
at the same time that's what the
complexity science is bringing to us is
is a more of a bottom-up vision of it
you know as as people who like Dionysius
or say maximus we tend to see it
top-down but when you read some
accidents you see that no he talks about
the love the love of the church as being
the manner in which the logos manifest
like yes that's it the communion of the
parts bottom-up is the the same thing as
the let's say that the top seed or the
name coming down from above it's the
same to drop a huge name I mean I I mean
I don't know how famous he is but he
certainly ought to be Eric pearl on you
know the neoplatonist philosopher I
think he's out in LA at a university but
he would remind us when we study with
him at Catholic you he said remember
that for Maximus every every on every
instance of deification is a further
instance of homina fication hmm and so
that that you know that unity that that
of what you just said is there I mean I
think the real issue for the West you
know it's what we now think of the West
Western Europe and that the Roman
Catholic and Protestant world is that
everything is a war between nominalism
and realism and at the moment you know
we're trying to let the Protestant
nominalist movement you know have its
full head and there's not nothing is
real everything is somehow imposed by
will or politics or oppression or
hierarchical bla bla bla and that war
between nominalism and realism just
cannot its fecund in a way I mean it's
it's it has been fertile for us in many
ways as the West but it's also quite
destructive and it's just not reality
and somehow in the East you overcome
that division between like you were just
saying between this arbitrariness versus
this kind of fixedness that's oppressive
yeah and I see that I see that right now
even in my discussions with people like
there's a there's a prop of cognitive
science John drove a key at University
of Toronto that I've having quite a few
discussions with and I think that he's
also discovered in in Maxis and you
Regina how the top-down and bottom-up
approaches are just the same that that
it's it's a mistake to say you can see
them as opposite in the sense of
perspectives but you don't want to see
them as opposing each other but rather
as exactly as just the perspective from
above and perspective from below
joined together in in love that's how
reality just that's how reality works
there's no way around it for every
object and for every instance of every
instance you can recognize needs to have
that pattern within it you know it's
it's so funny that you mentioned love
because you know everyone's trying to
develop a system without without
explicitly accounting for love and and
when Jane Jacobs turned her you know her
heart towards well from the very
beginning she said in in 1961 she said
the reason we've you know destroyed our
cities in the United States and in
England - to an extent as well is that
the people who were writing about cities
prescribing for cities trying to improve
cities were to a man and they were men
people who hated cities and and and she
says you know right there in 1961 she
says well it turns out with this new
kind of science that if you don't love
something you can never understand it
and I mean that is so um that destroys
the Enlightenment that that destroys and
then she right away picks up the pieces
into broken pieces and gives them back
to you she was really just the thing you
know the idea that Einstein was you know
the great mind of the 20th century
forget about it I would I'd much rather
you know curl up with all her writings
she understood and and when she wrote
about politics in her book system of
survival she says explicitly you know
there's this missing ingredient which is
love without which we cannot have a
civilization and I mean our social
justice people don't say that they're
just so anxious for revenge and you know
reform you know it's just the dead-end
street I always say love is is really
it's really and more the balance between
unity and multiplicity that's that's
love and that's the Trinity the the the
life of the very of the Trinity is the
infinite instantiation of that that
balance between one and many
and that's and you can't you can't have
any identity without without that you
know um and so I would like to get your
opinion on what's happening now because
you know in terms of people who see
patterns and see this pattern of
civilization and the pattern of how
things come together and how things are
separate we're living in a very strange
time with this with this virus and what
it's doing to us and I think that we
need to be able to to see it with that
lens and so I was wondering if you've
had some insights on what we're going
through right now oh I sure do it is
really good because for one thing we
don't know what we're going through I
mean it it's we're not sure whether it's
this is an overblown reaction what I'm
gathering is that you know that the full
might of Western you know industrial
power and scientific power I mean it's
it's like a it's like a battleship
that's slowly turning on this situation
I mean in another month that you know
we're gonna be drowning in surgical
masks we're gonna be you know self
testing twice a day for sure you know
and we are just gonna drown in that our
materialistic abundance and you know
let's do it let's do let's go for it
I think that's great you know but but
it's such an unknown enemy and I think
it's a good sign that people are trying
to this extent they can stay home but
while also trying to to reach out to
others you know by phone or whatever way
people saw jobs it's it's of course of
course I that the book that of course
you know was ringing in my mind is
Rodney starts the rise of Christianity
because he has a whole chapter about
plagues and epidemics and how they
impacted the growth of the church in the
first three centuries and another book I
have in mind is the grand strategy of
the business Ian Empire because in the
the so called plague of Justinian you
know some people think wiped out about
50% of the Byzantine Empire and so much
so that it's one of the few eras of
human history where greenhouse
is declined because you know the farms
drew over to forests and while the
animals picked off the livestock and
that's loot facts you know so so
certainly as a church or as a human race
plague has been you know with us and is
likely to be with us and certainly we're
learning a lot through this we're gonna
get sharper we're gonna get better we're
gonna monitor things more closely
someone is going to come up with faster
ways to create vaccines for these sorts
of things or you know if it really gets
out of control and you know the half the
Congress and that if the points of
police I'll get you know this plague or
something and they can't you know we
could just have a total collapse yeah
we'll see which one is well one of the
things that I've been noticing in terms
of how patterns are being you could say
with this and you know you can think
about it before it happened but when
it's happening all of a sudden you're in
it and so you're really just seeing it
play out is you know when you talk about
the fear and the unknown I think that
that is really part of it you know it is
part of the the notion of an unknown
agent or an or the idea of a of a
subversive agent within a system so you
have something that is there and you
don't totally know where it is what it's
doing but you know it's there and so the
fear of the subverted the subversive
agent is as important as the acts of the
subversive agent as you know the disease
itself which is breaking down the bonds
of society the fear that it's causing is
also is is part of the disease if you
can't you can't strip it away from what
the disease is it's not just a
biological thing it's a it's it stacks
up in terms of phenomena and as it
reaches the social level it's creating
this this fear and this of this unknown
and what it's doing is it's it's
isolating us from each other and so you
can see how in terms of a liturgical
thinking if you think of liturgy as
communion and think of liturgy as this
is balance between you know the the
oneness and the Manny and all of this
well the subversive agent
within the system is is breaking apart
is fragmenting the the system you know
and so with what can happen is that
either the system can be consumed or the
system will Oh like you said or the
system will then react and we'll we'll
try to reimpose itself sometimes to the
donor man of itself sometimes in a
balanced way that's the question is that
how how is the identity of whatever
systems were part of are going to kind
of reaffirm themselves is it going to be
a system are we gonna find ourselves in
a state of more control that's gonna
more control over us are we gonna find
some balance
um and then then that's when if you read
some of the accounts that you talked
about in terms of how the plague
participated in the rise of Christianity
you'd see how the fact that Christians
within plague settings continued to
demonstrate love and continue to care
for those who were sick and those who
were suffering that was I think I think
it was even Julian the apostate who had
to despite himself acknowledged how the
fact that Christians were doing this
within plague times was part of the
reason why the church grew and part of
the reason why it became stronger and so
I think that at the same time you know
even though we're doing this kind of
weird self-isolation thing there will be
moments as Christians where we will have
to transcend that and show the love of
Christ within within this this difficult
situation in order for the bond of the
church to server and also for the for
the system I hate to say the system or
the body of the church to thrive we need
to be able to to show how the love of
Christ can transcend the subversive
agent who that's breaking us apart I
know if that makes sense
it does you know I mean the the thing is
though that you know right now the the
mark the martyr ik frontline of all this
are the doctors and the nurses and I
know I've heard you know even here in
Massachusetts they're about to start
running out of masks and in gowns and
things and here we have all these great
hospitals so you know they are not
and in their posts and if if they start
to become you know sick then we really
will have a huge huge issue a society
you know crippling type of thing but
they're the ones asking us to stay home
they're the ones asking us to you know
don't play the hero yeah in a sense now
we have to be careful there because you
know we have Netflix now and you know
you just stay home and you you know you
binge watch or you do whatever some
friends it might have been joking there
they're actually gaining weight you know
they stockpile all this food and then
they're just nothing to do but eat it
you know ahead of schedule but you know
they're the ones asking us to stay home
and and yet at a certain point like you
said we will have to just throw caution
to the winds to minister to a neighbor
or or someone else and that's what
that's what I mean I would say that's
what Christians have always done but I
know that now those Christian values the
hospital itself was invented in the
fourth century and Asia Minor it's a
Christian artifact and now it belongs to
all civilizations everyone has those has
you know when a new value emerges in the
world you know through divine
inspiration in a sense it immediately
becomes the common earth right of all
yeah the extent they're able to live up
to it and so those are you know those
are our Christians and our martyrs are
these health care workers and other
people in that yeah well one of the ways
I think that that I think that at least
for now I mean we're not there's no
there's no the crisis isn't here totally
yet but I think that for now some of the
things I've seen people do and that
we've tried to participate in as well in
my home is to identify the elderly
people in our community that are really
self isolating more than everybody else
who are trying to stay in their house
and to see if we can be of service to
them to see if we can get groceries for
them if we can if we can do things to to
avoid them having to come to be in
public where they're more in danger
let's say of of getting it or being
affected by it that seems to be a simple
way to kind of help preserve the bonds
like I think that that's a way that I
see it is that is
to try to identify the way in which we
can counter the fragmenting effect of of
the subversive agent and rather preserve
the bonds you know I think the way a lot
of people have been criticized in people
criticized you know streaming the
services and everything people have
criticized that and I can understand
that ideally that is not the best thing
to do but we need to do with what we
have and try to to help people like I
said stay connected in the manner in
which we can at the moment and always be
and if we're attentive to that and we're
trying to look around us instead of
spending our time criticizing everything
looking around us and seeing what are
the practical ways in my life and then
the people around us where I can try to
preserve those bonds then we'll be doing
the healing we'll be doing the healing
that we can as the as the body of Christ
it's it's so crucially number the the
thing that you know of course the great
paradox of you know the ethics of beauty
here just to show it showed again is
that you know it starts off with a
discussion of trauma and the way in
which trauma you know disrupts
liturgical Communion the way war is kind
of an ante liturgy and really it just
always comes down so just what you said
of strengthening those bonds of finding
the excommunicated and reek communing
them and in her one of the final book
she completed Jane Jacobs Dark Age ahead
she writes with great pain about the
Chicago heat wave of I don't know what
year it was late 90s early 2000s and the
discovery so many people so many elderly
died that the CDC was tasked to figure
out what happened and one of the things
that was noted was that elderly who were
socially isolated to begin with we're
much more likely to die in the heat way
if when the power went out and they were
afraid even to open their doors for
let's say a social worker or someone who
came to help them so so she wrote about
that with great pain and we have to
figure that out and I I follow the email
I'm on the email list of this missus
frugal words
she's a an apostle of frugality up in
Vermont and I recommend her her emails
it's really good and she describes what
in hurt Vermont town of 400 people
how quickly they organized to have the
volunteer drivers volunteer organizers
and what someone needs something called
the organizer hey I need this the
drivers go pick it up at the store they
leave it on your porch there's no you
know you can let it sit there for an
hour till the you know the sunshine
blows off the virus or whatever but so
it's it's very important that we that we
try to stay connected we are about to
launch in today we're launching into our
experiment with distance education with
our students at Holy Cross in Hellenic
so we're gonna be very connected to our
students try to figure out hey you
didn't hand in your work yet getting all
that organized yeah that is a huge that
is definitely a huge step and we're
seeing everybody do that it's it's it's
it's all it's all it's a weird mix of
frightening and you know I it's in a way
we're happy that technology is
permitting us to do this right to even
have this discussion and to do this and
let's just I just have the fear that
we're creating permanent patterns we'll
see I hopefully we were not hopefully
that as as these as this wave kind of we
ride this wave then we will be able to
reconnect in more direct ways the danger
is that it's so convenient that there
might be a lot of residue of this kind
of weird disconnected connection that we
we said that we're setting up I hope
that for what happens for universities
you know because you could just have the
world's greatest lecturer give a lecture
and then you don't need the other twenty
thousand professors of that topic but I
hope what that will and you know
creating us as professors is an ability
to use the classroom time in ways that
are more personal and challenging and
problem-solving we try to do in my
Social ministries class we do an annual
simulation of a kind of broken society
and the students have to fix it and it's
it's those kind of things you know the
university should be stepping up their
simulations there
war games their their internships
they're on the you know the professor
instead of giving a lecture should just
come in and write a problem on the board
and and you know so I think this could
help us be better teachers take it as a
challenge for sure and so how do you
because you know I'm an icon Carver and
so obviously my interest in this
question of beauty and the question of
the relationship between the very
pattern of reality and in these these
systems that we create that we engage in
I'd like to get a bit of your sense of
let's say the state of liturgical art as
you kind of see it and and maybe also
how you see the the capacity for
Orthodox liturgical art to affect our
culture or modern culture right now big
question but yes this it seems like
we're we're undergoing a renewal and it
seems like it's been a long time
you know it's been a very slow growing
renewal and I think that I think the
momentum is certainly on the side of
better liturgical art and people more
and more aspire to that there's much
less aspiration for the the completely
unpadded novelty of of the 60s and 70s
so what we're really missing is just
enough practitioners enough education
and then sometimes the money because it
because a lot of times what's going on
is that it's the small parish that is
kind of insight rich but resource poor
and they know you know that if you can
get Andrew Gold's to build your church
then you know you're cooking with gas
now I mean that's the way okay but they
can't afford it or they can't afford him
but they can't afford to build the
church and so it we're just waiting it
would be nice you know to borrow up from
the page of the you know for the Italian
Renaissance
you know we it would be nice to have
some deep pocket
patron who would say look if you build
with one of these guys you know if it's
a show you're you're working with you
know I'll pay half right yeah
you're saying we need rushing it
oligarchs is that what you're saying I
would prefer Italian bankers there you
go you're very talented no I agree I
agree and I think one of the things that
needs to happen and I think this is kind
of falls back in your court as well and
not just your court but all the
seminaries in the United States is also
the future priests need to have that's
part of their education this is what I
believe I think that part of their
education has to be a capacity to
understand the importance of liturgical
art and the the capacity it has to
affect our our being especially in a
modern world of strip malls and you know
in electric lines and all this horrible
ugly stuff it seems like if the if the
clergy as they as we get more clergy if
the young clergy is at least attentive
to that and cares and know that it's
important then we're slowly going to be
it's not going to happen you know
tomorrow but we're slowly going to build
a culture of beauty back into you know
because we we have to also understand
the the madness that we're coming out of
you know we're coming out of the
communist regimes we're coming out of
the fascist states we're coming out of
you know a church the Orthodox Church
was beaten to the ground and so it's not
just everything is is now taking life
taking life again and so the arts also
have to find their place in that and in
America in a world of practicality and
in a world of budgets and thinking in
terms of the bottom line it's it seems
like it's a it's a tougher step to take
to really consider the liturgical arts
as part of what we need to to bring into
our communities as well you know Jane
Jacobs sort of sort of bring her into
everything but she's just so great she
said you know beauty is not to be had
for the asking you know you you you try
to build beautiful things but sometimes
it's not evident for you know a
generation or so
in weather you've hit the ball out of
the park or or kind of kind of whiffed
and and so so it's you know it's there
is some dimension of which it it really
is a miracle when some any whenever
anything beautiful gets made but but but
she also she also and I think Alexander
was was like and Wendell Berry too I
think probably the answer for a lot of
churches is to is to build a really
beautiful small chapel somewhere because
that does not have the same you know the
same complications of fire escapes and
whatever whatever in your main church
and if you're if your parish isn't ready
financially or or educationally to build
its parish church the right way at least
if these small side chapels off in the
country or even just across the street
or in a different part of the city can
be done well that's that's enough I
think that should be counted as a giant
victory I mean enough for now a parish
priest is essentially I mean besides
everything else that that he is he's the
mayor of a small village and and he's
got to keep that that community together
as you said including Maximus to the
extent that it's able possible I don't
think a beauty first way you know is
accepting of you know limitations and
you know we're doing the best we can
yeah but it's we're not that good right
now but I think also the the easy
accessibility of the cheap option is is
also hurting us in the sense that I one
of the things that I recommend people is
to don't get everything right away you
know everybody they want Hagia Sophia
you know right away and so if you want
that then of course and you'll get
prints all over your the church and
you'll get these massive prints that you
just glue on the on the wall and
everything because it's because you can
get all the icons where you can buy a
series of all the icons and it'll cost
you a few hundred dollars and you're
done
yeah and so
you you have to think more simply that
we need to start get one good icon get
to get you know and and if you're gonna
buy and I a painted icon get a good one
and then just slowly build from there
you know instead of going all out and
getting all the cheap stuff you know it
would be worth studying Saint John the
Baptist's the the the the real core
parish on 17th Street in Washington DC I
mean that is it is such a perfect Church
inside and you just wonder how in the
world did that happen I don't know the
history a I'm sure it's recounted on the
website but how they were able to
but but it's it's it's it's a challenge
I mean I I I certainly can I certainly
know bad art when I see it and and bad
architecture but I think as I've gotten
older I've gotten a lot less you know
critical and judgmental of it and partly
because we know that you know the bad
stuff won't last you know that it will
not be you know the next generation will
not preserve that thing that's a great
thing about understanding complex
systems as well is that you realize that
there's an actual natural process by
which ugly things get eliminated and
beautiful things get yet kept you know
it's like when they decide which
building they're gonna they're gonna
make a parking lot out of in the city
they're not gonna destroy that you know
300 200 year old neo-gothic church
they're going to you know get that ugly
building that ugly block of cement I say
that but it's happening in Europe sadly
as well they are because of the cost of
maintaining these buildings is difficult
there are some churches in Europe that
are getting at getting bulldozed up so
right I mean and if you lose the faith
entirely I mean it's hard to keep you
know beauty it's it's um and of course
there's something in the West a kind of
fun and Mark saw this and he and he he
condemned it you know he saw that you
know in a bottom-line culture that you
know nothing was sacred and nothing was
gonna withstand that and you know his
his answer was you know a kind of
violent rejection of of just everything
that had led up to that point and I mean
my point is that just the quality of our
own if you can fall in love with a
beautiful account of the life of San
Seraphim of Sarov you have changed
imperceptibly and invisibly the world
since situation yet you're different and
you you know that's gonna radiate out
and change the world it's gonna impact
the world at any rate yeah I agree I
agree and I think that and I I think I
think that we need to see that also that
that acts of beauty just like acts of
love in an interpersonal way that that
it is like these little stones that fall
into a pond and you don't know
the ramifications of what they have and
so we need to do kind of just advanced
you know I just make one icon at a time
and and I send them out into these
families into these parishes and it's to
me it's a it's a great joy to know that
I'm gonna be that I'm actually
participating in someone's life through
this act I'm creating something which is
part you know I'm I'm communing with
them in a way by giving them an object
that they will have in their prayer
corner that the part they'll give to
their niece who's getting baptized or
whatever it is they're going to do with
this icon that it's not it's not just an
object of consumption it's not just
something that you consume but it's
something that you participate in so yes
and you know it's better to make you
know one good one than you know five bad
ones I mean of course I think I think in
Orthodox cultures or just in in in in
just any mature culture anywhere in the
world that I I saw an interview with the
Dalai Lama said he pronounced the Dalai
Lama and he they had opened it a disco
near the base of his and they asked him
if he closed an interview what he
thought about that and he took him
awhile to understand the question and
then he just laughed because yeah he
understood that you know the these these
in substantial things they serve their
purpose they have their place it's it's
just it's just nothing it's just that
those of us who are called to do
something more enduring have to work a
little harder and do the do our jobs and
and you know they can coexist because
like I said the one is transitory and
the others you know it's forever yeah
and that's one of the things that once
you understand hierarchy properly you
understand that there's always a fringe
you should actually shouldn't get rid of
the fringe is there it has a proud it
it's problematic it's but it's not going
away it's just part of how reality
unfolds there's an art X there's a
fringe they're gargoyles on the outside
of the church it's just it's just part
of the pattern you just don't want to
confuse which place things have but what
we try to do is take those lower things
and elevate them to
value even that was interesting for a
while but I think it's it's important
when we are moved to to create those
higher things to marshal the support
financially and politically and whatever
parish politically and do those higher
things and let them endure yeah alright
dr. Tim it's a great conversation I'm
I'm gonna finish reading your book and
I'm hoping that if you want to I would
like to engage on some other aspects of
it once once I get through and and I
think also we're gonna see some
interesting discussion in the comments
section and I really encourage everybody
to to to get it like I said it's it
looks really thick but it's it's very
it's very nice to read because it it's
not a it's not a it's kind of a
in-between between a conversation and a
scholarly book it's not just totally
conversational but it's also not it's
not it doesn't have all these footnotes
and it's not constantly you know it's
not technical and so it's it's there
it's very much it follows the pattern of
what it's talking about which is the
idea of beauty and the idea of narrative
and pattern and how this is related to
communion and relationship and so the
fact that it's an interview also
participates in its meaning so I looking
forward to diving into it even more and
check out Hellenic college everybody for
yourself for your kids because we need
good places to learn and with dr.
Timothy there you you know that it's
going in a good direction at least
that's what I think for my kids so but
I'm just a tip of the iceberg you should
see how holy some of our professors are
but but I will say and if we talk again
well then I mention it in the book but
we can talk about what Jane Jacobs said
about icons so okay yeah definitely it'd
be great desert and she wasn't a
believer so so I trust her more because
you know she just she had that immediacy
in her she wasn't constrained by some
something else
yeah right she had it she just had an
intuition of what this was so yeah we'll
definitely dive into that Thank You
Jonathan I think that it was great to
talk to you I think you to your
listeners and viewers and all that hope
you enjoyed this interview with dr.
Timothy petits a-- you can check out the
description I will put a link to
his book also to Hellenic College and
Holy Cross as well as other projects in
which he is involved as you know
everybody who supports me monthly on
patreon on subscribe so are on my own
website you get a free patron only video
every month there are all kinds of
videos in there where I think there's
like nine or ten already and they keep
getting more and more out there someone
some fairy tales someone witches and
this month there's going to be a video
going deep more deeply into the story of
the golden hemorrhoids and mice related
to the question of an epidemic and so I
hope you all enjoy that thanks for your
support everybody stay safe in these
strange times and I will see you very
soon